[Music]
Davey I don't remember mommy being
pregnant with you I don't remember
seeing any pictures of her pregnant
either so now you think I'm adopted you
brought me an airplane to Ambush me with
this I just thought that maybe in Bonos
ciris we could try and find
out hi Mommy Diana dear we're Sav you
sleeping just keep an eye on here
don't worry this is really good for him
now that we're here don't you feel
something
whatever maybe you like to see some
authentic Tango It's Not For
[Applause]
[Music]
Tourists I want to dance with men
Argentinian men so much
theing do you think Tango is
oldfashioned sexist yeah but in a good
way Taps into something
Primal take off your juice you can't
petin those how do you like whenis are
you stay long just a few weeks our
parents are from here actually when did
your family move away I think it was
like the early 80s we were both really
little when we left the early 80s was a
difficult time here a lot of people left
to escape do you have your birth
certificate yeah I have it it has both
their parents names on it sometimes the
birth certificate contains false
information my whole life I felt like an
outsider and this
family and it's time to leave all this
where it belongs the past I know I
started this da I know I did I just
never imagined that it would my misery
is the only meaningful thing your
[Music]
life hello you have the result of your
DNA test we know the reason they left
here why didn't they want us to
[Music]
come